[Musique]
je pars à la retraite bon bah alors
qu'est-ce qu'on boit un verre pour ma
fille vous avez trouvé quelque chose
avec papa dans un train pendant la
guerre
un cadran qui pourrait changer
l'histoire pourquoi tu cours après la
chose qui a rendu ton père à moitié
dingue on ne bouge pas faut qu'on sorte
le professeur Jones trouver le
Clerc a commis des erreurs et je vais
les réparer grâce à ça vous l'avez volé
et vous ensuite et moi ensuite ça
s'appelle le capitalisme
à droite
attachez-vous professeurs nous ne sommes
pas à l'abri de turbulence tu as pris
des risques tu as fait des erreurs
et là tu t'offres un dernier triomphe
[Musique]
mais il m'est arrivé dans ma vie
in
je suis désolé
[Musique]
mais ça je l'ai cherché
toute ma vie
[Musique]